el cargo de Primer Ministro en vilo
aprueba en las urnas Yair lápiz que
encabeza una mayoría que reúne a varios
partidos de una izquierda debilitada del
centro de la derecha y de un partido
árabe intenta convencer a los ciudadanos
de que el rumbo trazado en los últimos
meses es el correcto próximo estas
elecciones son la transición entre el
pasado y el futuro Así que vayan a votar
por el futuro de nuestros hijos de
nuestro país voten bien buena suerte a
todos
si las encuestas no lean la victoria
tiene el ojo puesto en 60.000 votantes
religiosos decepcionados por la derecha
este electorado podría acercarlo más a
suministro de defensa y Aliado benigans
y poner en apuros al parlamento votantes
también codiciados por benjamine tan
Yahoo líder de licut en la derecha con
innumerables retornos desde su primera
llegada al poder en 1996 y juzgado hace
más de dos años por corrupción
netanyahu cuenta con su Aliado extrema
derecha y tamar Ben Beer quien aparece
aquí votando en un asentamiento de la
cisjordania ocupada su retórica
ultranacionalista atrae a un segmento
creciente del electorado pero muchos
ciudadanos están desilusionados por los
años de inestabilidad
No creo que también será lo mismo un
empate y el más listo formará gobierno
cumplo con mi deber como ciudadano y
espero que
sean las últimas de los próximos cuatro
años si no se forma una mayoría en las
elecciones ya irlapit puede permanecer
en el poder hasta que se celebre una
sexta votación su predecesor Benjamín
tan Yahoo estuvo en esta transición por
más de dos años como Primer Ministro